[Music]
hold on
I got eyes on Uncle muscle and the kid
all right everybody remember the plan
containing kidnap thank you
no no guns
alive
at least for a while
you ready ready
[Music]
all right
Oh no you're good you're good okay song
lyrics stub toes and Cannon cars
that was awesome
[Music]
you know we don't really be there if
Roman wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
see me shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican wow you guys
are going to hell
the great Dom tretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I'm the man that's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
how about we all just start shooting
each other
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
cheers we need weapons and cars
you like surprises I adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's overdone you lose
you lost track
then you might want to buckle up
[Music]